The Joe Rogan experience. And in another case I saw it was a magpie.
One of these birds known for how smart it is. There is a full,
uh, you know, half liter, um, you know, plastic, uh,
thing of water. It was just water. Okay. You know,
a water bottle and it was full. So that magpie goes over and sips out the water.
Now you can own it.
The beak is only what an inch and a half long or an inch at most.
So it goes in until it can't reach the water anymore. So what does it do?
It goes off to the side, gets a rock, just the right size,
drops it into the water bottle and raises the level of
thereby displacing water. Here it is. You've got the, there it is.
And so it's how it comes. And it goes back and gets another stone,
drops it in.
And every time it drops it in the water level rises and it can drink more water
and it just, it keeps doing this. That's pretty amazing. Okay. And so,
so every time we study animals,
they're smarter than we ever thought they were.
So maybe for our own ego,
we kept building ourselves up saying how separate and distinct we are as
humans in the animal kingdom,
when maybe we're not as separate and distinct as we think we are.
So now what, what's my broader point there about that. I was making,
I just distracted myself. I I'm trying to get back to UFO's on that.
The fact that we.
Have high resolution cameras in our pocket, and we take videos of things.
That are very unusual. Exactly.
So here's video of a magpie doing Bernoulli experiments on a,
on a, on a water, in a water bottle who would have known that even happened.
Right. Okay.
You can't bring the bird into a lab and S and then maybe you could,
but I don't know that anyone did all right. Here's my point. Um,
in the 1960s and seventies, there were many, many reports of alien abductions.
People said to the aliens, came to me and they brought me in,
and then they released me. Do you have any footage? No.
They took my camera or no, they zapped my, my film.
And now there's no image on the film, but there were countless stories. Well,
now you can stream live from your
camera, anything that's going on in front of you.
So if the aliens come and they want them ducky to stream it,
that would be instantly viral. Oh my gosh.
You know, the stuff that goes viral is much less than that. A cat that kitten,
that jumps to the table and falls that goes viral.
You don't think of video footage of an alien.
It's not going to go viral instantly, but there's none.
So I'm just saying, I'm thinking if we were being visited,
somebody would have some good footage. If we were being visited,
I'm thinking maybe Google satellite images would catch spaceships that are not
airplanes moving on our surface. If we were being visited,
I I'm thinking we'd have something better than fuzzy monochromatic
video of, of,
of objects that apparently reveal themselves only to Navy pilots. Right? So.
I mean,
one of the reasons is most of these sightings actually occur far off shore in
the ocean. And the speculation is, this is one of the ways,
obviously I'm going to put my tinfoil hat on nice and tight.
This is one of the ways that they monitor us the best way to do it is to do it
where their hold, their base, where no one is around, which is the ocean. No,
that's not true. Go in the ocean. They pop up and they fly out. It's not true.
What do you mean? It's not true. It's not true.
Yeah. Nobody lives on the ocean. Yes, that's correct.
But have you have you well, so, oh, it leaves lives down under C.
This is what the speculation,
that's why these transmedium devices have been these trans medium
crafts have been observed.
One, if you are sure,
we you're being visited by aliens and you don't actually have really good
evidence, then you have to say that.
Sure. Well, you know that.
You have to say that you have to say,
this is really happening and they're observing us and they're concealing
themselves in this particular way. You have to say that. So that's the,
that's sort of, that's your way to maintain your, your,
your alien belief system by saying that,
and I don't have a problem with it. Go get him, go get him.
But all of what has been put forth as evidence for aliens to me
is insufficient evidence to excite my interest,
my research interest in devoting time to finding it out.
But it definitely is excited. Other people I have not stopped them.
I am not saying defund the military, uh,
program on UAPs, which of course has just updated.
UFO right now. They like to say that that's that stigma.
I know. That's just that that's a really transparent. No, no.
It's not even sneaky. It's actually, I think it's embarrassing.
It's like maybe if we call them UAP.
No,
it's just I'm of the belief that they're probably akin to what we did on Mars.
I don't think there's aliens in them.
I have a feeling that these things are probes.
And I feel like if you just think about biological entities flying through the
universe, like, why do that? When you have sophisticated technology,
that's good enough right now from our like relatively
primitive and consideration of what we think is possible a million years from
now. Right. But we can send that Mars Rover around.
We have a helicopter on Mars. I mean,
there's multiple satellites flying through the universe right now,
taking images. We, we can do all that. Yeah.
Probes are not targeting the Martian
military fighter.
Because there's no marsh and military, but if there were, we certainly.
Out in the.
Open, right. But if we had something like, are you familiar with, um,
one of the most famous cases was a case with a commander,
David Fravor of the Navy who, uh,
encountered with one or two other jets off of the Nimitz.
They encountered this thing that was shaped like a tic-tac. Yeah.
You know, the, somebody knows this, this story.
It went from,
they tracked it going from 80,000 feet above sea level to 50 in less
than a second, they have no idea how it moved.
There's no visible propulsion system. It was blocking their radar.
It was actively blocking, tracking.
Sensors told them exactly. Just be clear about that.
Then you're stating information as though it is.
Facts. I'm stating information as commander. I don't.
Care that that doesn't matter. He's human. Right. We're all human here.
But as a scientist, when you're presenting information,
you don't say this thing was at 80,000 feet and it dropped to zero to
C-level in one second or whatever it was that the measure that's,
that's the wrong way to report it.
What you say is we have sensors that told
us this is what I understand what you're saying. Okay. Yeah.
That's a very important distinction. Yes. And so,
so now, all right,
your first question then tell me about the sensors. Yeah. Okay.
Or how are they double-checked or are they, you know? And so, so,
but if you just going to say, there's this craft at 80,000 with it,
then everyone is thinking about a craft and no one is thinking about the sensor
they actually.
Saw with their eyes to, this is something that they actually.
You can't see something at 80,000 feet. No.
The V the actual visual on the crowd. Okay. They didn't see it at 80,000 feet,
but this craft, it's not just something that was tracked with the.
Got it. But they didn't see it at 80,000 feet. That's my point. So,
so by the way, this level of that, uh, that, of,
of attention I'm giving to the detail and the reporting of information,
we do that with fellow scientists for much less. Oh,
for sure. Then if we're being visited by intelligent aliens,
from another planet, go visit a goat,
go to a scientific conference and watch the level of scrutiny we put on other
people's work. If they have a sensor that has a new result, we'll say,
did you calibrate the sensor? Did you, how long has the sensor been in use?
What? I I'll give you an example. Here's an example. Okay. Um,
do you remember planet X, the search for planet X Nibiru?
Uh, that was one, uh, there was sorry,
there was several incarnations of planet X, right? That was among them. Okay.
I'm talking about a hundred years ago. Planet X. Okay. A hundred years ago.
Well, there's several planet. X's right. So, um,
Uranus was moving weirdly. Nobody understood. Maybe there's a planet beyond it.
Whose gravity we have yet to reckon in our equations. Oh, boom.
We discovered Neptune, wait a minute. Neptune is moving a little, a little,
uh, unfamiliar, really? Where my phone is. Sorry about that.
Drop that thing and break it with no case.
So yeah, I got the 12 and yeah, I can still do this. I'm just,
sorry. It's not true.
Last time you were here, you had a broken case. There's a broken back.
So, uh, w why are you distract me?
I was like on a roll and Neptune Neptune. So, so Neptune,
we're looking at Neptune's orbit and it's not following Newton's
laws. And this is odd. Well, we've been down that road before Uranus.
Didn't follow you in the, as we proposed another planet and we found it.
So Neptune's not following all the laws of gravity,
that from all the other planets and the sun,
there must be another planet out there.
A planet EXCOM let's look for it is that Bode's law, both law is a,
is it fitting function that gets you, it,
it got a little more attention than it deserved. It's just a planets. Um,
every next planet is about twice as far away from the sun as the previous one.
So you just make a quick equation out of that,
but it doesn't work for mercury and it didn't work for Pluto.
And I thought it was based on the mass of the planet. No, not at all.
That has nothing to do. And it predicted the asteroid belt,
but the asteroid belt, there's no planet there. Right. Okay. And if you add,
if you glue together, all the pieces of the asteroid belt,
you get something like 5%, the mass of the moon. So yeah,
it gave us a location in the asteroid belt, but that's not a planet.
So Bode's law, it's fun to play with. But you know,
there limits to how far you want to declare its relevance to the
actual universe. So we're out here in Neptune. And so it's, as I said,
maybe there's a planet X here, but he started looking.
Everybody started looking including Percival, Lowell, all right.
Back in the 1920s. And he said,
I want to find planet X because something's perturbing Neptune.
So he sets out looking for it and he doesn't find it.
Then he hires Clyde Tombow and he dies.
So he doesn't see the results of this Clyde Tombow. He said,
I can't find it either. I will just systematically search everywhere.
Because if you think something's affecting you gravitationally,
you ought to have some idea where it is to be tugging on you in that way.
Right. That's not, it's not some kind of weird. It's like,
you're moving differently.
Where must the thing be to tug on you so that you moving in that way?
No one could find such a planet X. So Kleinberg Tahmoh said,
it's gotta be out there somewhere. I will systematically image the entire sky.
All right.
And you got to do it on multiple nights because if something's moving,
you'd see it change from one picture to the next.
He does this discovers Pluto was Pluto where planet X was supposed to have been
no was Pluto. The mask that planet X should have been.
Everyone assumed it was,
but over the decades and the master Pluto got lower and lower and lower as our
estimates got more and more accurate. And then we found out that is,
is one fifth, the mass of our moon made of half ice.
And this is why Pluto got into trouble later in the, in the 20th century.
It's not, it's not because we had some vendetta against Pluto.
Pluto just never belonged in that list to begin with.
That's really how you need to think about it. Anyhow,
there's still the matter of Neptune's orbit.
Pluto did not have enough mass to make those changes.
So the search for planet X continued. So what happens? All right.
Uh, 1993,
a colleague of mine named miles Standish. Okay.
He's probably related to the miles Standish on the Mayflower.
He is an astrophysicist looked at all of the data.
People were using to say, Neptune's orbit was crooked. Look at all the data.
Then he found out that at one particular observatory,
was it the gearbox or the timing mechanism had just been
cleaned or swapped out? Or there was some that because,
and when in the observing log,
you write down everything because you just don't know, okay.
Was there a glitch in the current, was there a bird fly over?
You make notes of everything.
One of the observatories whose data was being grafted together with the other
observatories had this sort of gearbox. My F I don't remember it was a gearbox.
There was some mechanical adjustment that was made. He said,
I wonder if that had an effect on the positioning of this
telescope. He remove those data from his analysis
and fitted data to all the other telescopes that he had for the positions of
Uranus and Neptune. When he did that
planet X evaporated in that instant,
in that instant, there was no planet X, all the other data.
When he connects across removing the data from the one where the observing log
said they did something different, uh, uh,
Neptune fell right on to Newton's laws. And so,
so since 1993, there is no planet X and Pluto. And,
and were it not for that?
We probably would have been a long time before we discovered Pluto because no
one would have looked for it. They found another, like, what was it?
The lesson there? Okay. The lesson there is,
you have information that you think is correct from your sensors.
This was an observatory. If I find observatory,
and you're gonna say this observatory says Neptune is misbehaving,
but then you learned there was something wrong with the data you throw it out.
So, uh, so I'm just, I'm trying to say this happens all the time in science.
You have to be careful what you're analyzing before you declare that what the
thing measured is true,
and then realign all your resources to address what you think is true.
When it might've just simply been a glitch or multiple glitches or, or anything.
And we do this all the time in science.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free, only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan.